a finales de los ochentas y comienzos de
los noventas cuando nosotros comenzamos
nuestras carreras terminando la
universidad
y en ese momento se hablaba de un estado
fallido colombia perdía la batalla
frente al crimen organizado en una
especie de pulso en donde estaba de un
lado la institucionalidad el estado y de
otro lado estaba el crimen organizado
representado por esas tres variables el
narcotráfico que era mucho más
organizado que la justicia el conflicto
armado que tiene una potencialidad de
reventar la justicia porque además se
daba en territorios de colombia donde el
estado no estaba y no sigue estando en
la mayoría de los casos y la corrupción
que es un mal que ayuda a dicho nace
crece se reproduce no muere se
transforma se sofistica se moderniza
entonces decimos nosotros por un lado
está el crimen organizado y por el otro
lado está un sistema de justicia estatal
completamente desorganizado porque eso
es importante es importante para
entender en qué momentos llegamos a este
punto de buelvas ustedes 30 años
lo han visto ustedes seguramente por
netflix exclusivamente o en las series
del patrón del mal y vayan a la ciudad
de medellín a comienzos de los 90 y
había un señor que pagaba
por matar un policía y dos mil dólares
por matar un juez y mató decenas de
jueces gente
esa era colombia a comienzos de los 90
pues qué pasó siempre los americanos
apareció el tippingpoint que es como la
gota que rebosó la copa y que rebosó la
copa rebosó la copa que nosotros
comenzamos a trabajar en lo público
haciendo política en los cementerios así
de dramático así de dramático porque
mataron tres candidatos presidenciales
por que exterminaron un partido político
el doctor álvaro gómez hurtado ustedes
saben lo asesinaron en la puerta de esta
universidad y esto no son historias no
son leyendas obedecen a realidades del
pasado inmediato de colombia que es lo
que nos forjó a nosotros en una forja
además bastante complicada y ahí nos
encontramos una multiplicación de las
víctimas ustedes saben quién es
prácticamente a 9 millones de
colombianos el último registro de las
víctimas en colombia son 8 millones 800
mil colombianos
todo eso ha supuesto que quien le ponía
la cara a todo esto
quién se llevará el lap o
fortalecimiento de la justicia y aparece
una idea y esta historia que les estoy
contando en la historia de la fuerza de
las ideas en la historia de la obra en
un momento en que no había tecnología en
un momento donde no existían las redes
sociales nosotros no teníamos un
teléfono celular lo que había era un
aparato que muchos de ustedes ni conocen
que es un fax que era como una
fotocopiadora gigante así de grande
donde se le tomaba una foto del
documento y no la pasaba como por un
rodillo y eso le llegaba a otra persona
en otra parte del mundo
fucks y de labia conseguimos que la idea
se fuera para adelante y cuál fue la
idea de vida fue decir vamos a reformar
la constitución de colombia y vamos a
fortalecer la justicia algo que todo el
mundo estaba diciendo bien pese a que en
colombia no hay justicia
y arrancamos y arrancamos y eso se fue
convirtiendo en
y esa fue la séptima papeleta y por qué
se llamó la séptima papeleta porque iba
a haber un proceso electoral el 11 de
marzo de 1990 hace 29 años y ese día los
colombianos iban a depositar 6 papeletas
dentro de la urna no se votaba como
ahora con un tarjetón electoral
lindísimo super moderno donde unas
casillas de ustedes ponen a equis
no señoras y señores se votaba metiendo
unas papeletas dentro de un sobrecito
entonces se nos ocurrió
que metiéramos el séptimo papelito
entonces se hace voto por senadores por
representados por concejales por
alcaldes fue la primera vez que se
eligieron los alcaldes popularmente la
segunda
por primera vez se eligió el candidato
de un partido en una consulta del
partido que estaba decidida dentro de
ese mismo decisión el de marzo y lo que
dijimos fue metamos el papelito que
ustedes lo tienen que diseñar les estoy
contando no había redes sociales
entonces le pedimos a todos los
periódicos de colombia
que imprimiera en las páginas de los
periódicos la séptima papeleta le
decíamos a los campesinos si esto era
por radio coja un papelito de estas
dimensiones de 12 x 8 centímetros se
escriba a voto por una asamblea nacional
constituyente que reforme la
constitución nacional y esto se
convirtió en la bola de nieve que ya
mencioné
el arrasador
al punto que el presidente de la
república que el presidente virgilio
barco dijo aquí une
en ese momento no había posibilidades
legales de hacer una asamblea nacional
constituyente porque todas las reformas
había que hacerlas a través del congreso
pero fue el poder de una idea el que se
impuso el poder de un sueño el que ganó
esa batalla simplemente para dejar la
elección a usted es que cuando hay
participación convicción las realidades
vienen de la mano con esos procesos
todo eso además supuso el concepto más
importante que una cosa que ustedes en
este momento no se puede en un país tan
fracturado tan polarizado como está
colombia en este momento nadando siempre
entre los extremos yo siempre he dicho
que parte de la tragedia que estamos
viviendo es por una parte nuestra
incapacidad de hablar con los que no
piensan no sienten como uno cuando
tienen ningún mérito uno de armar
acuerdos con la gente que piensa igual
que uno que se dedicó como uno
o que está en la misma situación que uno
aquí lo que tiene mérito es hablar con
el contrario aquí lo que tiene mérito es
sentarse a construir un país que sea de
todos como lo dijo la misma constitución
de 1991 y de ahí llegamos al consenso
político más importante que ha tenido
colombia mucho más importante que el
frente nacional el frente nacional tuvo
un plebiscito el primero de diciembre
del 57 y de todas las constituciones de
colombia eran el conciliábulo de
expertos que se sentaban por orden de un
presidente a redactar las normas
constitucionales la anécdota de esa
época era pase me el lápiz que yo voy a
legislar le decía a un presidente a su
secretaria eso pasó a la historia y vino
el agua del amo gracia participativa y
una de la ub de los nuevos propósitos
del estado y sobre todo se puso como
columna vertebral de todo este proceso
constituyente la necesidad de edificar
un estado garante de los derechos de los
ciudadanos
y por eso yo he dicho muchas veces el
garante ético más simple de colombia es
la constitución de 1991 la humana como
premisa mayor de todo lo demás es el
fortalecimiento de la justicia en ese
proceso constituyente se crearon las
nuevas instituciones de la justicia y el
hecho de haber arrinconado y derrotado
como se dio a los grandes cárteles de la
droga fue consecuencia de cómo se
fortaleció el poder judicial en colombia
que ustedes van a decir ah no pero eso
está repleto de escándalos hoy en día si
la corrupción más grandes de la que se
halla hoy dentro del poder judicial por
cuenta del cartel de la toga pues eso no
fue así en este momento ese historial de
esa montaña rusa los altos de la montaña
roja llevaron precisamente a la
posibilidad de que la justicia actuara y
apareció la acción de tutela el
instrumento utilización más importante
que tiene la justicia en colombia el
único que ha bajado la justicia a los
niveles de red
no logro pero la constitución del 91 y
apareció la corte constitucional que
ustedes han visto la línea que hacen en
la defensa de los derechos económicos y
sociales en colombia todas esas
instituciones que han sido tan
importantes y hoy frente a lo que
estamos viviendo para llegar a hoy viene
pues toda esa discusión de qué vamos a
hacer con los derechos de 8 millones 800
mil colombianos que tienen que ser
restablecidos y ese es el sentido de una
justicia que puede ser absolutamente
imperfecta como es la justicia especial
para la paz pero lo que tenemos lo que
salió de un acuerdo que hay que
rectificar la por rectificamos la como
toca pero que hay que tener en mente
únicamente el restablecimiento de los
derechos yo les cuento una experiencia
personal antes de ayer
fue el 9 abril fue el más y ayer estuve
yo en cali con los familiares de los
diputados que fueron asesinados por las
farc hace 12 años después de 5 años de
secuestro es donde las cosas que sólo
pasan en colombia este nivel de
aproximación a la violencia y este nivel
de levantarse las instituciones a
rechazar la violencia sólo se da en el
caso de colombia y oír los testimonios
ya no de quienes vivieron de manera
directa esa tragedia que yo del yo les
diría fue la tragedia más grande fue el
acto más horroroso que pudo cometer las
farc dentro de todo este proceso porque
los secuestro los tuvo en cautiverio 5
años y nadie sabe por qué todavía
ninguno de los familiares que lo que
todos pedían ayer en la ciudad de cali
decía mire ayúdenos en la red donde esta
gente nos cuente por qué asesinaron a
nuestros familiares pero ustedes vieron
la visión de la segunda generación y
aquí empató con lo que quiero terminar
porque están las nuevas generaciones
está una visión distinta de lo que está
pasando ustedes ya pertenecen a una
generación donde estos escenarios de la
justicia de alguna manera toda esta
tragedia radical debió quedar atrás y
ustedes llegan con unos elementos de
juicio y unos propósitos ante la vida
que tienen se tienen que ser distintos
lo que yo vi en términos de perdón de
reconciliación de reconstrucción incluso
de muchos que dieron mira a mí me costó
más trabajo que otros
las hijas de los diputados que hoy son
abogadas de las universidades en cali
una llegaron a
pero y otras llegaron después
pero allí hay un proceso de
restablecimiento de derechos por
supuesto los estamos acompañando en las
instancias judiciales del caso para que
eso llegue a su feliz término
lo siguiente que me parece muy
importante ustedes tienen en ese asunto
de cuál es la pala que es la insignia de
la generación de ustedes algo mucho más
de lo que representó la justicia para mi
generación con todas las frustraciones
que tenemos después de llevar tres
décadas en esta lucha y la lucha sigue
porque a mí lo que me toca hacer todos
los días de aquí en adelante usted saben
que la competencia constitucional de la
procuraduría es defender el orden
jurídico y defender los derechos de los
colombianos siempre en función del
interés público y ahí viene la propuesta
ustedes tienen que marcar con el sello
de su generación su compromiso con
colombia y por dónde viene ese
compromiso por una palabrita que es el
déficit y la bancarrota más grande que
tiene colombia que es precisamente la
ética y la ética que ha sido
un valor tan desconocido en colombia esa
justa en la que los va a llevar a
ustedes a un puerto seguro a un puerto
seguro desde el punto de vista
generacional porque lo que ustedes les
ofrece la tecnología en este momento
siempre tiene que estar gobernado por
esos principios y esos valores porque el
compromiso con el medio ambiente que es
otra de las grandes matrículas
generacionales de ustedes también es
resultado de una reflexión ética y sobre
todo porque la gran traba que ustedes
van a tener como generación profesional
y diaria es seguir con la desigualdad en
colombia la desigualdad esto lo repetido
muchas veces es como una fábrica del
sistema político la desigualdad está ahí
remueve los cimientos del sistema
político desde el punto de vista
jurídico afecta a los derechos de la
gente luego tengan la certeza que de
aquí en adelante el nombre de la
generación de ustedes conmigo fue la
justicia es de ustedes era la ética
los liderazgos que prosperan en este
siglo liderazgos que tienen que estar
derivados de ahí
y que acuden a la palabra y aquí termino
como comencé el tema de la justa palabra
no es el tema de la palabra polarizadora
radical extremista exclusionista que se
agrega es todo lo contrario
toda esa lógica del vocabulario de mi
generación déjenlo atrás este tema de de
por debaje ar como se dice con lo que
eres como nos ha pasado recientemente
tratando una persona que tiene unas
condiciones de profesionalismo decirle
niña o indio o negro o para ccoo
guerrillero
ese es el volteo que ustedes tienen que
darle al uso del vocabulario en esta
generación y partan de la base que por
eso o nosotros recuperamos la ética en
este país o si nos el país entre las
manos muchísimas gracias por su atención
[Aplausos]